hello everyone I haven't done an elation
video in a while so I thought why not
make an alien video the game was played
in 1924 it was a simultaneous exhibition
Alexandra Jackson held in New York and
well he got a very decent result 17 wins
zero zero draws and one loss but two of
the games and that simultaneous
exhibition were played blindfold so I
don't know if one if that game that he
did lose was the blindfold game or not I
couldn't really find the game he lost
but this game he has the white pieces
against Leon Koosman and do not mistake
mr. Leon Koosman for for the for the
chess master Abraham Guzman who also
lived in that era as they are not the
same person which some people are
mistaking them and the game is very
interesting how a legend well in in a
well-known theoretical position takes a
great advantage of a small inaccuracy in
the opening by mr. Guzman so a Lincoln
goes for d4 we have d5 Knight to f3
Knight to f6 c4 and these six
transposing into the Queens gambit
declined Knight to c3
now c5 we have C captures on d5 and here
mr. Koosman replies with you capture sin
b5 and I can here here says that Knight
captures on d5 would be a much better
option for black as well
white simply gets too much out of the
position as well
- all right 11 played already this game
two years ago against the new mr. Reed
Mar also a well known player but okay
mr. Koosman went eke after Sun d5 and
the Bishop to g5 was played and Bishop
to e6 and now a liaison captures the
knight Bishop captures on f6 Queen
captures on f6 and now II for well a
very nasty move for black back has to
decide what to do here he captures on d5
is the threat and well the best move is
to capture the upon which mr. Koosman
does D captures on e4 and Bishop to b5
check and mr. Koosman replies with
Bishop to d7 blocking the check slightly
better move would be nice to be seven
but this
also leads to an advantage for white
after for example Knight captures on e4
with an attack on the Queen Queen g6 and
a Bishop capture 77 Bishop captures and
white can freely castle as this Knight
cannot be captured and the white is
better here
the knight can be captured because of
rook e1 but okay after Bishop to b5
check Bishop to d7 was played and now we
have Knight captures on e4 would attempt
on the Queen Queen to b6 attacking the
bishop bishop capture son d7 would check
now after sandy 718 castles and well mr.
Koosman definitely doesn't want to allow
Aleichem to push d5 this would be this
would be a very strong pawn a very
strong past born so Koosman decides to
capture it but maybe maybe a lesser evil
as eilean said himself would be to allow
him to play d5 well okay see characters
on d4 was played and Knight captures on
d4 rook to d8 and now I let in plays
Knight to f5 and already this is a this
is a beautiful night and f5 is gonna be
very hard for black to play this
position we have Knights the e5 opening
up the attack from the rook and the
Queen Queen to e2 and g6 now attacking
the knight on f5 and this g6 move is is
a terrible blunder here I didn't place
Queen to b5 check offers a Queen
sacrifice as his queen is unprotected on
b5 and the Queen cannot be captured if
Queen captor son b5 you get to the
knight to f6 with checkmate a beautiful
smothered mate with two knights but
after Queen to b5 he does have the
option of playing Knight to d7 which was
played but now I live in plays a rook F
2 e1 again offering his queen and again
the Queen cannot be captured as well if
the queen is captured the knife captures
and f6 is still checkmate as now it's a
double check from the knight and the
rook so after rook F 2 e1 mr. Guzman try
the Bishop to b4 me making a an escape
route for his King and f8 and I didn't
play Knight to f6 with with a double
check
we have King 2f8 Knight captures on d7
with check for King the king and the
Queen so the knight has to be captured
rook captures on d7 and here I haven't
played Queen to e5 and in this position
mr. Koosman resigned the game as well
threatening at least three checkmate is
too much for black to handle and he
doesn't want to play this game anymore
28 check me this coming Queen captures
an HH Eckman is coming and of course
when the g7 checkmate is coming so
anything black really does if he
captures the knight Queen captures on h8
is checkmate and the well there really
isn't any other move worth showing even
with the best defense with a ceiling
like Queen captures an f2 just
prolonging it's still checkmate in five
moves so yeah a very nice win by
election in this game and also in the
entire blindfold exhibition if I managed
to find that one game he lost I will
show it as well I do hope you enjoyed
this game and if you're a Queen's Gambit
player maybe you maybe you can find the
use for this game in your own games and
I would like to thank Kenneth McKay for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual guys
you can check my two two previous videos
here thank you for watching and I will
see you soon